Blais-Morin. Bonjour à tous ceux
qui nous écoutent.
- Monsieur Duclos, on est à
notre septième vague de COVID.
À quel point les tests
aléatoires à la frontière ont
permis d'anticiper les dernières
vagues ou l'arrivée de nouveaux
variants? En clair, ce que
j'essaie de voir, là, avec vous,
c'est : est-ce qu'on a la preuve
que ces tests aléatoires
à la frontière sont efficaces?
- Bien, deux réponses.
La première, lorsque les tests
étaient obligatoire pour tous
ceux et pour toutes celles qui
rentraient au pays, évidemment,
ils servaient un rôle majeur,
c'est-à-dire que tout le monde
savait, une fois rentré au pays,
si elle ou lui avait la COVID,
donc permettait à cette personne
de s'isoler en cas de positivité
au test. Maintenant qu'ils sont
aléatoires, ils restent encore
très importants, parce que
premièrement, on les fait
s des aéroports, donc il
y a pas d'enjeu d'infrastructure
ou de disponibilité de personnel
dans les aéroports. Tout se fait
en dehors du contexte
aéroportuaire. Mais tout demêmet
de suivre l'entrée de variants
au pays, qui sont les voyageurs
qui sont affectés par ces
variants, d'où ils arrivent, et,
par conséquent, nous permettent
de mieux comprendre la situation
épidémiologique au pays.
Comme on le sait, la COVID-19
continue d'évoluer rapidement,
avec de nouveaux variants,
de nouveaux sous-variants, et
cette information scientifique
sur la virologie de la COVID-19
est très importante.
- Par exemple, quand on parle du
variant Omicron, ça se transmet
rapidement, plus rapidement
que la COVID au tout début.
À quel point c'est nécessaire
de savoir que ça entre par
la frontière? C'est comme si
quand on le sait, à
trop tard. Le variant, il est
déjà ici, monsieur le ministre.
- Tout à fait. Donc, l'objectif
n'est pas de bloqus
lorsqu'ils entrent au pays.
L'objectif est d'avoir
une méthode scientifique
relativeoûteuse, qui
comporte beaucoup... très peu
d'ennuis pour les gens. Donc,
une méthode scientifique
e par la se par la se par la see
du gouvernement canadien
pour documenter la nature
et l'évolution des variants.
nt les variants qui
rentrent? En quelles quantités?
De quelles provenances?
Ça nous permet aussi detravaille
internationale avec d'autres
pays qui, comme nous,
font ce genre de travail.Et en r
une technique que tout le monde
connaît maintenant, les tests...
qui sont des tests très précis
et qui nous donnent la nature
exacte du virus dont les gens
peuvent être affecté lorsqu'ils
arrivent au pays.
- Est-ce que vous faites
le criblage de tous ces tests
pour vérifier la présence de
variants?
- Tout à fait. Tous les tests
sont criblés. Tous les tests
positifs, évidemment,
sont criblés.
- Les voyageurs, monsieurvous lu
ces dernières semaines dans
les nouvelles, ils ont parfois
fait un parcours du combattant
pour partir à l'étranger,
pour revenir, aussi, au retour.
Donc, quand c'est pas les
passeports, ce sont les fils,
les annulations de vols,
les bagages, parfois, qui posent
problème. Est-ce que les
avantages que vous pensez avoir
avec ces tests aléatoires,
donc un meilleur portrait de
la situation, comme vous dit
est-ce que ça pèse plus lourd
que les inconvénients que vous
imposez au public voyageur,
qui est parfois déjà excédé,
en leur demandant,
d'aller prendre un rendez-vous
pour surveiller leur test
aléatoire?
- Soyons clair : il y a zéro
procédure qui a lieu dans
les aéroports avec la nouvelle
méthode qu'on utilise pour les
tests aléatoires. C'est pour ça
qu'on a reporté au 19 juille
prochain le retour de ces tests
aléatoires. Donc, il y a rien,
absolument rien, pas
d'inscription, pas d'opération
de tests qui vont se passer
à l'aéroport. Tou
en dehors des aéroports,
tout en, comme on le disait,
permettant à la blique
de continuer à avoir des
informations utiles et précises
sur le vts
et sur les gens qui peuvent être
infectés une fois qu'ils entrent
- N'empêche, il faut quand même
le faire, le test. C'est ça que
je vous dis : il y a quand même
une étape de plus
voyageur.
- Tout a fait. Il y a à peu près
3 à 4 % des gens qui rentrent
au pays qui vont, à leur guise,
une male
se faire tester une fois qu'ils
seront rentrés au pays, après
le passage aux aéroports, pour
permettre aux Canadiens et
nadien de
continuer à avoir des meilleures
informations possibles sur
le variant, sur les variants
et sur la COVID-19.
- Monsieur le ministre,
on a la chance de vous avoir
à l'émission. Petite questionqus
au cours des derniers jours :
les provinces exigent depuis
des mois de s'asseoir avec
Justin Trudeau sur les
transferts en santé; est-ce
êt à nous dire
à quel moment va se tenir
la rencontre?
- Si vous me permettez, j'arrive
immédiatement. J'aimerais aussis
écoutent, que pour continuer
de lutter contre la COVID-19,
il est absolument essentiel
d'avoir cette vaccinationà jours
relations avec les provinces et
territoires : trois choses.
La première, c'est qu'on a
démontré au cours des dernières
années à quel point on pouvait
travailler ensemble pour
protéger la santé et la sécurité
des Canadiens, y compris,
évidemment, des Québécois.
La deuxième chose, c'est que ce
modèle collaboratif continue. On
continue de travailler ensemble
avec des investissements records
de la part du gouvernement
canadien pour veiller aux
besoins les plus urgents
des provinces et des territoires
en matière de soins de santé.
En plus des 45 mil
transferts canadiens en santé,
les 72 milliards associés
à la COVID-19, un autre
2 milliards que j'ai annoncé
il y a quelques semaines pour
réduire les retards en matière
de chirurgies, de traitements
et de diagnostics, et d'autres
milliards en santé mentale,
en soins à domicile et en soins
de longue durée. Mais il y a
des défis de long terme auxq
on doit se tourner.
Notre population vieillit.
Et le premier ministre Trude
l'a dit : on va être là pour
aider les provinces et les
territoires, dans
leurs compétences, pour traiter
de ces défis majeurs qui
nous attendent.
- Monsieur le ministre,
je comprends que vous n'êtes pas
prêt encore à nous donner
cette date-là. Je rappelle que
vous êtes minist